The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at oct.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: All right.
So let's continue talking about
maximum likelihood estimation
in the context of generalized
linear models, all right?
So in those generalized
linear models,
what we spent most of the
past lectures working on
is the conditional
distribution of Y given
X. And we're going
to assume that this
follows some distribution
in the exponential family.
OK.
And so what it means is that if
we look at the density, say--
or the PMF, but let's
talk about density
to make things clearer--
we're going to assume that
Y given X has distribution.
So X is now fixed, because
we're conditioning on it.
And it has a density, which
is of this form, c of Yi phi.
OK.
So this c, again, we don't
really need to think about it.
This is something that's
going to come up naturally
as soon as you need
normalization factor.
And so here what it means, if
this is the distribution of Y
given Xi, so that's
the density of Yi
given Xi is equal to little xi.
So if it's the conditional
distribution of Yi given Xi,
it should depend on xi somehow.
And it does not appear
to depend on Xi.
And here, the model is going
to be on theta i, which is just
a function, theta i of Xi.
And we're going to take
a very specific one.
It's going to be a function
of a linear form of the Xi.
So really we're going to take
something which is of the form
theta I, which is really
just-- as theta does not depend
on Xi--
of Xi transposed from beta.
OK?
So all these parts here,
this is really some modeling
assumptions that we're
making once we've agreed
on what distribution we want.
OK.
So to do that, our
goal, of course,
is going to try to
understand what this beta is.
There's one beta here.
What's important is that this
beta does not depend on i.
So if they observe
pairs Xi, Yi--
let's say I observe n of
them, i equals 1 to n--
the hope is that as a
accumulate more and more pairs
of this form where there's
always the same parameter that
links Xi to Yi, that's
this parameter beta,
that I should have a better and
better estimation of this beta.
Because it's always the same.
And that's essentially
with couples
all of our distribution.
If I did not assume
this, then I could
have a different distribution
for each pair Xi given YI.
And I would not be able
to do any statistics.
Nothing would
average in the end.
But here I have the
same beta, which
means that I can hope to
do statistics and average
errors in them.
OK.
So I'm going to collect,
so I'll come back to this.
But as usual in the
linear regression model,
we're going to collect
all our observations Yi.
So I'm going to assume
that they're real valued
and that my Xi's
takes value in Rp
just like in the
regression model.
And I'm going to collect all my
Yi's into one big vector of Y
in our n and all my X's into
one big matrix in Rn times p
just like for the
linear regression model.
All right, so, again, what
I'm interested in here
is the conditional
distribution of Yi given Xi.
OK.
I said this is
this distribution.
When we're talking
about regression,
I defined last time
what the definition
of regression function was.
It's just one
particular aspect of
this conventional distribution.
It's the conditional
expectation of Yi given Xi.
OK.
And so this conditional
expectation,
I will denote it by--
so I talk about the
conditional, I'm
going to call it,
say, mu i, which
is the conditional
expectation of Yi given
Xi equals some little xi, say.
You can forget about this
part if you find it confusing.
It really doesn't matter.
It's just that this
means that this
is a function of little xi.
But if I only had the
expectation of Yi given big Xi,
this would be just a
function of big Xi.
So it really doesn't
change anything.
It's just a matter of notation.
OK.
So just forget about this part.
But I'll just do
it like that here.
OK.
So this is just the conditional
expectation of Yi given Xi.
It just depends on Xi, so
I think it depends on i,
and so I will call it mu i.
But I know that since in a
canonical exponential family,
then I know that mu i is
actually B prime of theta i.
OK.
So there's a 1 to 1 link
between the canonical parameter
of my exponential
family and the mean mu
i, the conditional expectation.
And the modeling assumption
we're going to make
is not directly--
remember, that was
the second aspect
of the generalized linear model.
We're not going to assume
that theta i itself directly
depends on Xi.
We're going to
assume that mu i has
a particular dependence on
Xi through the link function.
So, again, we're
back to modeling.
So we have a link function g.
And we assume that mu i
depends on Xi as follows.
g of mu i--
and remember, all g
does for us is really
map the space in which
mu i lives, which
could be just the interval
0, 1 to the entire real line,
all right?
And we're going to assume
that this thing that
lives in the real line is
just Xi transpose beta.
I should maybe put a small
one, Xi transpose beta.
OK?
So we're making, indeed,
some modeling assumption.
But compared to in the
linear regression model,
we only assume that mu
i was Xi transpose beta.
So if you want to
make a parallel
between generalized
linear models
and linear model is
the only difference
is that g is not the identity
necessarily in this case.
And all the g does
for us is to just
make this thing
compatible, that those two
things on the left and
the right of equality
live in the same space.
So in a way, we're not making
a much bigger leap of faith
by assuming a linear model.
The linear link is already here.
We're just making things
compatible, all right?
And so it's always the
same link function.
So now if I want to
go back to beta--
right, because I'm going to
want to express my likelihood--
if I were to express my
likelihood from this,
it would just be a
function of theta, right?
And so if I want to
maximize my likelihood,
I don't want to
maximize it in theta.
I want to maximize it in beta.
So if I can write my density
as a function of beta,
then I will be able
to write my likelihood
as a function of
beta, and then talk
about my maximum
likelihood estimator.
And so all they need to
do is to just say, OK,
how do I replace theta by--
I know that theta is a
function of beta, right?
I wrote it here.
So the question is,
what is this function?
And I actually have
access to all of this.
So what I know is that theta--
right, so mu is
b prime of theta,
which means that theta i
is b prime inverse of mu i.
OK.
So that's what we've got from
this derivative of the log
likelihood equal to 0.
That give us this guy inverted.
And now I know that mu i
is g inverse of Xi beta.
So this composition of b
prime inverse and g inverse
is actually just the
composition of g with b prime.
Everybody's comfortable
with this notation,
the little circle?
Any question about this?
It just means that I
first applied b prime.
Well, actually, it's D inverse.
But if I look at a function
g composed with b prime,
I first applied the g b prime
of x, is just g of b prime of x.
OK.
And then I take the
inverse of this function,
which is first take g inverse,
and then take b prime inverse.
OK.
So now I have
everywhere I saw theta,
now I see this function of beta.
So I could technically
plug that in.
Of course, it's a
little painful to have
to write g circle beta
prime all the time.
So I'm going to give
this guy a name.
And so you're just
going to define
h, which is g b prime inverse
so that theta i is simply
h of Xi transpose beta.
OK.
I could give it
a name, you know.
But let's just call
that the h function.
And something which is
nice about this h function
is that if g is the
canonical link--
what is the canonical link?
So what is it canonical to?
A canonical link, it's canonical
to a particular distribution
in the canonical
exponential family, right?
A canonical exponential family
is completely characterized
by the function b.
Which means that if I want to
talk about the canonical link,
all I need to tell you
is how it depends on b.
So what is g as a function of b?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: b inverse.
b prime inverse, right?
So this is g is equal to
b prime inverse, which
means that if g is composed
with b prime that means
that this is just the identity.
So h is the identity.
So h of Xi transpose beta
is simply Xi transpose beta.
And it's true that the way we
introduce the canonical link
was just the function for
which we model directly theta i
as Xi transpose beta, which
we can read off here, right?
So theta i is simply
Xi transpose beta.
So now, for example, if I go
back to my log-likelihood,
so if I look log-likelihood,
the log-likelihood
is sum of the log
of the densities.
So it's sum from i equal 1 to n
of log of exponential Yi theta
i minus b theta i divided
by phi plus c of Yi phi.
So this term does
not depend on theta.
So I have two things.
First of all, the log
and the exponential
are going to cancel each other.
And second, I actually
know that theta is just
a function of beta.
And it has this form.
Theta i is h of
Xi transpose beta.
And that's my
modeling assumption.
So this is actually equal to the
sum from i equal 1 to n of Yi.
And then here I'm going to
write h of Xi transpose beta
minus b of h of Xi transpose
beta divided by phi.
And then I have,
again, this function
c of Yi phi, which
again won't matter.
Because when I'm going to
try to maximize this thing,
this is just playing
the role of a constant
that's shifting the
entire function.
In particular, your max is
going to be exactly what it was.
OK?
So this thing is really
not going to matter for me.
I'm keeping track of it.
And actually, if you look
here, it's gone, right?
It's gone, because
it does not matter.
So let's just pretend
it's not here,
because it won't
matter when I'm trying
to maximize the likelihood.
OK?
While it's here up to
constant term, it says.
That's the constant term.
All right, any question?
All I'm doing here is replacing
my likelihood as a function
of theta i's.
So if I had one theta
i per observation,
again, this would not
help me very much.
But if I assume that they
are all linked together
by saying that theta i is of
the form Xi transpose beta
or h of Xi transpose beta if I'm
not using the canonical link,
then I can hope to
make some estimation.
And so, again, if I
have the canonical link,
h is the identity.
So I'm left only with Yi
times Xi transpose beta.
And then I have b
of Xi transpose beta
and not b composed with h,
because h is the identity,
which is fairly simple, right?
Why is it simple?
Well, let's actually focus
on this guy for one second.
So let me write it down, so we
know what we're talking about.
So we just showed that the
log-likelihood when I use
the canonical link--
so that h is equal
to the identity,
the log-likelihood
actually takes the form ln.
And it depends on
a bunch of stuff.
But let's just make it
depend only on the parameter
that we care about,
which is beta, all right?
So this is of the form l of
beta and that's equal to what?
It's the sum from i equal 1 to n
of Yi Xi transpose beta minus--
let me put the phi here.
And then I'm going to have
minus b of Xi transpose beta.
OK.
And phi we know is some
known positive term.
So again, optimizing a
function plus some constant
or optimizing of function
time as a constant,
that's not going to
change much either.
So it won't really matter to
think about whether this phi is
here or not.
But let's just think about
what this function looks like.
I'm trying to
maximize a function.
I'm trying to maximize
a log-likelihood.
If it looked like this, that
would be a serious problem.
But we can do like a
basic, you know, back
of the envelope guess of what
the variations of this function
is.
This first term here is--
as a function of beta, what
kind of function is it?
AUDIENCE: Linear.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
It's linear, right?
This is just Xi transpose beta.
If I multiply beta
by 2, I get twice.
If I add something to
beta, it just gets added,
so it's a linear
function of beta.
And so this thing is
both convex and concave.
In the one-dimensional
case-- so think about p
as being one-dimensional--
so if beta
is a one-dimensional
thing, those
are just the function that
looks like this, right?
Those are linear functions.
They are both
convex and concave.
So this is not
going to matter when
it comes to the convexity
of my overall function,
because I'm just adding
something which is just a line.
And so if I started with convex,
it's going to stay convex.
If I started with concave,
it's going to stay concave.
And if I started with
something which is both,
it's going to stay
both, meaning neither.
It cannot be both.
Yeah.
So if you're neither convex or
concave, adding this linear--
so this will not really matter.
If I want to understand
when my function looks like,
I need to understand would
b of Xi transpose beta does.
Begin, the Xi transpose beta--
no impact.
It's a linear function.
In terms of convexity, it's
not going to play any role.
So I really need to understand
what my function b looks like.
What do we know about b again?
So we know that b prime of
theta is equal to mu, right?
Well, the mean of
a random variable
in a canonical
exponential family
can be a positive
or negative number.
This really does not
tell me anything.
That can be really anything.
However, if I look at the
second the derivative of b,
I know that this is what?
This is the variance
of Y divided by phi.
That was my
dispersion parameter.
The variance was equal to
phi times b prime prime.
So we know that if
theta is not degenerate,
meaning that the
density does not
take value infinity
at only one point,
this thing is actually positive.
And clearly, when
you have something
that looks like this, unless you
have some crazy stuff happening
with phi being equal to 0 or
anything that's not normal,
then you will see that
you're not degenerate.
So this think is
strictly positive.
And we've said several times
that if b prime prime is
positive, then that means that's
the derivative of b prime,
meaning that b
prime is increasing.
And b prime is
increasing is just
the same thing as saying
that b is convex, All right?
So that implies that
b is strictly convex.
And the strictly
comes from the fact
that this is a strict sign.
Well, I should not do that,
because now it's no longer.
So it's just a
strict sign, meaning
that the function, this
is not strictly convex,
because it's linear.
Strictly convex
means there's always
some curvature everywhere.
So now I have this thing that's
linear minus something that's
convex.
Something that's negative,
something convex, is concave.
So this thing is
linear plus concave.
So it is concave.
So I know just by looking at
this that ln of beta, which,
of course, is something
that lives in Rp,
but if I saw it living in
R1 it would look like this.
And if I saw it
living in R2, it would
look like a dome like this.
And the fact that
it's strict is also
telling me that it is
actually a unique maximizer.
So there's unique maximizer
in Xi transpose beta,
but not in beta necessarily.
We're going to need extra
assumptions for this.
OK.
So this is what I say here.
The log-likelihood
is strictly concave.
And so as a consequence under
extra assumptions on the Xi
is because, of course, if the
Xi's are all the same, right?
So if the entries of Xi's--
so if Xi is equal
to 1, 1, 1, 1, 1,
then Xi transpose beta is
just the sum of the betas.
And of the beta i's, I will be
strictly concaving those guys,
but certainly not in
the individual entries.
OK.
So I need extra thing on my
Xi, so that this happens,
just like we needed
the matrix capital
X in the linear regression
case to be a full rank,
so we could actually
identify would beta was.
OK.
It's going to be
exactly the same thing.
So here, this is when we
have this very specific
parametrization.
And the question is--
but it may not be the case
if we change the parameter
beta into something else.
OK.
So here, the fact that we use
the canonical link, et cetera,
everything actually works
really to our advantage,
so that everything
becomes strictly concave.
And we know exactly
what's happening.
All right, so I understand
I went a bit fast
on playing with convex
and concave functions.
This is not the purpose.
You know, I could
spend a lecture
telling you, oh, if I add
two concave functions,
then the result remains concave.
If I had a concave and
a strictly concave,
then the result still
remains strictly concave.
And we could spend
time proving this.
This was just for you
to get an intuition
as to why this is correct.
But we don't really have time
to go into too much detail.
One thing you can do--
a strictly concave function,
if it's in one dimension,
all I need to have is that the
second derivative is strictly
negative, right?
That's a strictly
concave function.
That was the analytic definition
we had for strict concavity.
So if this was in
one dimension, it
would look like this,
Yi times Xi times beta.
Now, beta is just one number.
And then I would have
minus beta Xi times b.
And this is all over phi.
You take second derivatives.
The fact that this is linear in
beta, this is going to go away.
And here, I'm just going
to be left with minus--
so if I take the second
derivative with respect
to beta, this is going to be
equal to minus b prime prime Xi
beta times Xi squared
divided by phi.
So this is clearly positive.
If Xi is 0, this is degenerate,
so I would not get it.
Then I have the
second derivative
of b prime, which
I know is positive,
because of the variance
thing that I have here,
divided by phi.
And so that would all be fine.
That's for one dimension.
If I wanted to do this
in higher dimensions,
I would have to say
that the Hessian is
a positive definite matrix.
And that's maybe a bit
beyond what this course is.
So in the rest of
this chapter, I
will do what I did
not do when we talked
about maximum likelihood.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to actually show how to
do this maximization, right?
So here, we know that
the function is concave.
But what it looks
like specifically
depends on what b is.
And for different b's, I'm going
to have different things to do,
Just like when I was talking
about maximum likelihood
estimation, if it had a concave
log-likelihood function,
I could optimize it.
But depending on
what the function is,
I would actually
need some algorithms
that may be working better on
some functions than others.
Now, here I don't
have random things.
I have the b is the
cumulant generating
function of a canonical
exponential family.
And there is a way for me
to sort of leverage that.
So not only is there the
b part, but there's also
the linear part.
And if I start
trying to use that,
I'm actually going to be
able to devise very specific
optimization algorithms.
And the way I'm going
to be able to do this
is by thinking of
simple black box
optimization to which I can
actually technically feed
any function.
But it's going to turn
out that the iterations
of this iterative
algorithms are going
to look very
familiar when we just
plug in the particular values
of b, of the log-likelihood
that we have for this problem.
And so the three methods we're
going to talk about going from
more black box-- meaning you can
basically stuff in any function
that's going to work, any
concave function that's going
to work, all the way to
this is working specifically
for generalized linear models--
are Newton-Raphson method.
Who's already heard about
the Newton-Raphson method?
So there's probably some people
actually learned this algorithm
without even knowing the
word algorithm, right?
It's a function.
Typically, it's supposed to
be finding roots of functions.
But finding the root of a
function of the derivative
is the same as finding
the minimum of a function.
So that's the first
black box method.
I mean, it's pretty old.
And then there's
something that's
very specific to what we're
doing, which is called--
so this Newton-Raphson
method is going
to involve the Hessian
of our log-likelihood.
And since we know
something about the Hessian
for a particular problem,
we're going to be able move one
to Fisher-scoring.
And the word Fisher here
is actually exactly coming
from Fisher information.
So the Hessian is going to
involve the Fisher information.
And finally, we will talk about
iteratively re-weighted least
squares.
And that's not for any function.
It's really when
we're trying to use
the fact that there is this
linear dependence on the Xi.
And this is essentially going
to tell us, well, you know,
you can use least squares
for linear regression.
Here, you can use least
squares, but locally,
and you have to iterate.
OK.
And this last part is
essentially a trick
by statisticians
to be able to solve
the Newton-Raphson
updates without actually
having a dedicated
software for this,
but just being able to reuse
some least squares software.
OK.
So you know, we've talked
about this many times.
I just want to make sure that
we're all on the same page
here.
We have a function f.
We're going to assume that
it has two derivatives.
And it's a function
from Rm to R.
So it's fist derivative
is called gradient.
That's the vector that collects
all the partial derivatives
with respect to each
of the coordinates.
It's dimension m, of course.
And the second derivative
is an m by m matrix.
It's called the Hessian.
And ith row and
jth column, you see
the second partial
derivative with respect
to the ith component
and the jth component.
OK.
We've seen that several times.
This is just
multi-variable calculus.
But really the point here
is to maybe the notation
is slightly different, because
I want to keep track of f.
So when I write the gradient,
I write nabla sub f.
And when I write Hessian,
I write nabla H sub f.
And as I said, if f
is strictly concave,
then Hf of x is
negative definite.
What it means is that if
I take any x in Rm, then x
transpose Hf, well,
that's for any X0 X,
this is actually
strictly negative.
That's what it means to
be negative definite.
OK?
So every time I do x transpose--
so this is like
a quadratic form.
And I want it to be negative
for all values of X0 and X,
both of them.
That's very strong, clearly.
But for us, actually,
this is what happens just
because of the properties of b.
Well, at least
the fact that it's
negative, less than
or equal to, if I
want it to be strictly less
I need some properties on X.
And then I will call the
Hessian map the function
that maps X to this
matrix Hf of X.
So that's just the
second derivative at x.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When you
what are [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Where do [INAUDIBLE]??
Oh, yeah.
I mean, you know, you need to
be able to apply Schwarz lemma.
Let's say two continue
derivatives that's smooth.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
No, that's fine.
OK.
So how does the
Newton-Raphson method work?
Well, what it does is that it
forms a quadratic approximation
to your function.
And that's the one it optimizes
at every single point.
OK.
And the reason is
because we have
a closed-form solution
to defining the minimum
of a quadratic function.
So if I give you
a function that's
of the form ax squared
plus b x plus c,
you know exactly a closed
form for its minimum.
But if I give you any
function or, let's say--
yeah, yeah.
So here, it's all about maximum.
I'm sorry.
If you're confused with
me using the word minimum,
just assume that it
was the word maximum.
So this is how it works.
OK.
If I give you a function which
is concave, that's quadratic.
OK.
So it's going to look like this.
So that's of the
form ax squared--
where a is negative, of course--
plus bx plus c.
Then you can solve
your whatever.
You can take the derivative of
this guy, set it equal to 0,
and you will have
an exact equation
into what the value of x is
that it realizes this maximum.
If I give you any
function that's concave,
that's all clear, right?
I mean, if I tell you the
function that we have here
is that the form
ax minus b of x,
then I'm just going to have
something that inverts b prime.
But how do I do that exactly?
It's not clear.
And so what we do is we do a
quadratic approximation, which
should be true approximately
everywhere, right?
So I'm at this point
here, I'm going to say,
oh, I'm close to
being that function.
And if I'm at this
point here, I'm
going to be close to
being that function.
And for this function,
I can actually optimize.
And so if I'm not moving too
far from one to the other,
I should actually get something.
So here's how the quadratic
approximation works.
I'm going to write the second
order Taylor expansion.
OK.
And so that's just going to
be my quadratic approximation.
It's going to say, oh,
f of x, when x is close
to some point x0,
is going to close
to f of x0 plus the gradient of
f at x0 transpose x minus x0.
And then I'm going to have
plus 1/2x minus x0 transpose
Hf at 0x x minus x
transpose, right--
x minus x0.
So that's just my second
order Taylor expansion
multi-variate 1.
And let's say x0 is this guy.
Now, what I'm going
to do is say, OK,
if I wanted to set this
derivative of this guy
equal to 0, I would
just have to solve,
well, you know, f
prime of x equals 0,
meaning that X has to
be f prime inverse of 0.
And really apart from like being
some notation manipulation,
this is really not helping me.
OK.
Because I don't know
what f prime inverse of 0
is in many instances.
However if f has a very
specific form which
is something that depends
on x in a very specific way,
there's just a linear term
and then a quadratic term,
then I can actually
do something.
So let's forget
about this approach.
And rather than
minimizing f, let's just
minimize the right-hand side.
OK.
So sorry- maximize.
So maximize the right-hand side.
And so how do I get this?
Well, I just set the
gradient equal to 0.
So what is the gradient?
The first term does
not depend on x.
So that means that this
is going to be 0 plus--
what is the gradient of this
thing, of the gradient of f
at x0 transpose x minus x0?
What is the gradient
of this guy?
So I have a function of
the form b transpose x.
What is the gradient
of this thing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I'm sorry?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I'm writing
everything in two-column form,
right?
So it's just b.
OK.
So here, what is b?
Well, it's gradient of f at x0.
OK.
And this term here gradient
of f at x0 transpose x0
is just a constant.
This thing is
going away as well.
And then I'm looking at the
derivative of this guy here.
And this is like
a quadratic term.
It's like H times
x minus x0 squared.
So when I'm going to
take the derivative,
I'm going to have
a factor 2 that's
going to pop out and
cancel this one half.
And then I'm going
to be left only
with this part times this part.
OK.
So that's plus Hf x minus x0.
So that's just a gradient.
And I want it to be equal to 0.
So I'm just going to
solve this equal to 0.
OK?
So that means that if I
want to find the minimum,
this is just going to be
the x* that satisfies this.
So that's actually equivalent
to Hf times x* is equal to Hf x0
minus gradient f at x0.
Now, this is a much
easier thing to solve.
What is this?
This is just a system of
linear equations, right?
I just need to find the x* such
that when I pre-multiply it
by a matrix I get this vector
on the right-hand side.
This is just something
of the form ax equals b.
And I have many
ways I can do this.
I could do Gaussian
elimination, or I
could use Spielman's
fast Laplacian solvers
if I had some particular
properties of H. I mean,
there's huge activity in terms
of how to solve those systems.
But let's say I have some time.
It's not a huge problem.
I can actually just
use linear algebra.
And linear algebra just tells me
that x* is equal to Hf inverse
times this guy, which those
two guys are going to cancel.
So this is actually equal to
x0 minus Hf inverse gradient f
at x0.
And that's just what's
called a Newton iteration.
I started at some x0.
I'm at some x0, where I
make my approximation.
And it's telling me
starting from this x0,
I wanted to fully optimize
a quadratic approximation,
I would just have
to take the x*.
That's this guy.
And then I could just use this
guy as my x0 and do it again,
and again, and again, and again.
And those are called
Newton iterations.
And they're basically
the workhorse
of interior point methods,
for example, a lot
of optimization algorithms.
And that's what
you can see here.
x* is equal to x0 minus
the inverse Hessian times
the gradient.
We briefly mentioned
gradient descent.
We briefly mentioned gradient
decent, at some point,
to optimize the convex
function, right?
And if I wanted to use gradient
descent, again, H is a matrix.
But if I wanted to think
of H as being a scalar,
would it be a positive
or negative number?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Why?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
So that would be this.
So I want to move against
the gradient to do what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: To minimize.
But I'm maximizing here, right?
Everything is maximized, right?
So I know that H is
actually negative definite.
So it's a negative number.
So you have the same
confusions they do.
We're maximizing a
concave function here.
So H is negative.
So this is something of
the form x0 plus something
times the gradient.
And this is what your gradient
ascent, rather than descent,
would look like.
And all it's saying,
Newton is telling
you don't take the
gradient for granted
as a direction in
which you want to go.
It says, do a slight change
of coordinates before you
do this according to what your
Hessian looks like, all right?
And those are called second
order methods that require
knowing what the Hessian is.
But those are actually
much more powerful
than the gradient
descent, because they're
using all of the local
geometry of the problem.
All of the local
geometry of your function
is completely encoded
in this Hessian.
And in particular it
implies that it tells you
where to switch and not to
go slower in some places
or go faster in other places.
Now, this in practice for,
say, modern large scale
machine learning problems,
inverting this matrix H
is extremely painful.
It takes too much time.
The matrix is too big, and
computers cannot do it.
And people resort
to what's called
pseudo-Newton method,
which essentially tries
to emulate what this guy is.
And there's many
ways you can do this.
Some of them is
by using gradients
that you've collected
in the past.
Some of them just say,
well let's just pretend H
is diagonal.
There's a lot of
things you can do
to just play around this
and not actually have
to invert this matrix.
OK?
So once you have this,
you started from edge 0.
It tells you which H* you can
get as a maximizer of the local
quadratic approximation
to your function.
You can actually just
iterate that, all right?
So you start at
some x0 somewhere.
And then once you
get to some xk,
you just do the iteration
which is described,
which is just find
a k plus 1, which
is the maximizer of the
local quadratic approximation
to your function at xk and
repeat until convergence.
OK.
So if this was an
optimization class,
we would prove that convergence
actually, eventually,
happens for a strictly
concave function.
This is a stats
class, so you're just
going to have to trust
me that this is the case.
And it's globally
convergent, meaning
that you can start
wherever you want, and it's
going to work for under
minor conditions on f.
And in particular,
those conditions
are satisfied for the
log-likelihood functions
we have in mind.
OK.
And it converges at an
extremely fast rate.
Usually it's
quadratic convergence,
which means that every
time you make one step,
you improve the accuracy of
your solution by two digits.
If that's something you're
vaguely interested in,
I highly recommend that
you take a class on them
in your optimization.
It's a fascinating topic.
Unfortunately, we
don't have much time,
but it starts being more
and more intertwined
with high dimensional
statistics and machine learning.
I mean, it's an algorithms
class, typically.
But it's very much
more principled.
It's not a bunch of algorithms
that solve a bunch of problems.
There's basically
one basic idea,
which is if I have
a convex function,
I can actually minimize it.
If I have a concave
function, I can maximize it.
And it evolves around
a similar thing.
So let's stare at this iterative
step for a second and pause.
And let me know if you
have any questions.
OK.
So, of course, in a
second we will plug in
for the log-likelihood.
This is just a general thing
for a general function f.
But then in a second,
f is going to be ln.
OK.
So if I wanted to
implement that for real,
I would have to compute the
gradient of ln at a point xk.
And I would have to compute
the Hessian at a given point
and invert it.
OK.
So this is just the
basic algorithm.
And this, as you can
tell, used in no place
the fact that ln was the
log-likelihood associated
to some canonical
exponential family
in a generalized linear model.
This never showed up.
So can we use that somehow?
Optimization for longest time
was about making your problems
as general as possible
accumulating maybe
in the interior point method
theory in Koenig programming
in the mid-'90s.
And now what
optimization is doing
is that it's [INAUDIBLE]
very general.
It' says, OK, if I want
to start to go fast,
I need to exploit as much
structure about my problem
as I can.
And the beauty is
that as statisticians
are a machine
learning people, we
do have a bunch of
very specific problem
that we want
optimizers to solve.
And they can make
things run much faster.
But this did not require to
wait until the 21st century.
Problems with very
specific structure
arose already in this
generalized linear model.
So what do we know?
Well, we know that this
log-likelihood is really
one thing that comes
when we're trying
to replace an expectation
by an average,
and then doing
something fancy, right?
That was our statistical hammer.
And remember when we introduced
likelihood maximization we just
said, what do we
really want to do
is to minimize the KL, right?
That's the thing we
wanted to minimize,
the KL divergence between two
distributions, the true one
and the one that's parameterized
by some unknown theta.
And we're trying to
minimize that over theta.
And we said, well,
I don't know what
this is, because it's an
expectation with respect
to some known distribution.
So let me just replace the
expectation with respect
to my unknown distribution by
an average over my data points.
And that's how we
justified the existence
of the log-likelihood
maximization problem.
But here, actually, I
might be able to compute
this expectation, at least
partially where I need it.
And what we're going to do
is we're going to say, OK,
since at a given point xk,
say, let me call it here theta,
I'm trying to find the
inverse of the Hessian
of my log-likelihood, right?
So if you look at the
previous one, as I said,
we're going to have to compute
the Hessian H sub l n of xk,
and then invert it.
But let's forget about the
inversion step for a second.
We have to compute the Hessian.
This is the Hessian
of the function
we're trying to minimize.
But if I could
actually replace it
not by the function I'm
trying to minimize to maximize
or the log-likelihood,
but really
by the function I wish I
was actually minimizing,
which is the KL, right?
Then that would be really nice.
And what happens is
that since I'm actually
trying to find
this at a given xk,
I can always pretend
that this xk that I have
in my current iteration
is the true one
and compute my expectation
with respect to that guy.
And what happens is
that I know that when
I compute the expectation of the
Hessian of the log-likelihood
at a given theta and when I take
the expectation with respect
to the same theta,
what I get out
is negative Fisher information.
The Fisher information
was defined in two ways--
as the expectation of the square
of the derivative or negative
of the expectation of
the second derivative
of the log-likelihood.
And so now, I'm doing some
sort of a leap of faith here.
Because there's no way the
theta, which is the current xk,
that's the current theta
at which I'm actually
doing this optimization--
I'm actually pretending
that this is the right one.
But what's going to
change by doing this
is that it's going to
make my life easier.
Because when I
take expectations,
we'll see that when we
look at the Hessian,
the Hessian as essentially the
derivative of, say, a product
is going to be the sum
of two terms, right?
The derivative of u times v
is u prime v plus uv prime.
One of those two
terms is actually
going to have expectation 0.
And that's going to make
my life very easy when
I take expectations
and basically just
have one term that's
going to go away.
And so in particular,
my formula,
just by the virtue of
taking this expectation
before inverting the
Hessian, is going
to just shrink the size
of my formulas by half.
OK.
So let's see how this works.
You don't have to believe me.
Is there any question
about this slide?
You guys remember
when we were doing
maximum estimation
and Fisher information
and the KL
divergence, et cetera?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Because
that's what we're really
trying to minimize.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
So there's something
you need to trust me
with, which is that the
expectation of H of ln
is actually H of the
expectation of ln, all right?
Yeah, it's true, right?
Because taking derivative
is a linear operator.
And we actually used
that several times when
we said expectation of partial
of l with respect to theta
is equal to 0.
Remember we did that?
That's basically
what we used, right?
AUDIENCE: ln is the likelihood.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: It's
the log-likelihood.
AUDIENCE: Log-likelihood,
[INAUDIBLE] OK.
When we did Fisher
[INAUDIBLE],, we
did the likelihood of
[INAUDIBLE] observation.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why is
it ln in this case?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So actually,
ln is typically not normalized.
So I really should
talk about ln over n.
OK.
But let's see that, OK?
So if I have IID observations,
that should be pretty obvious.
OK.
So if I have IID x1, xn, with
density f theta and if I look
at log f theta of Xi, sum from
i equal 1 to n, as I said,
I need to actually
have a 1 over n here.
When I look at the
expectation, they all have
the same expectation, right?
So this is actually,
indeed, equal to negative KL
plus a constant.
OK?
And negative KL
is because this--
sorry, if I look
at the expectation.
So the expectation of this guy
is just the expectation of one
of them, all right?
So I just do expectation theta.
OK?
Agree?
Remember, the KL was expectation
theta log f theta divided by f.
So that's between p
theta and p theta prime.
Well, no, sorry.
That's the true p.
And let's call it f.
p theta, right?
So that's what showed
up, which is, indeed,
equal to minus
expectation theta log
f theta plus log of f, which
is just a constant with respect
to theta.
It's just the thing
that's up doesn't matter.
OK?
So this is what shows up here.
And just the fact that
I have this 1 over n
doesn't change,
because they're IID.
Now, when I have things that are
not IID-- because what I really
had was Y1 Yn, and Yi at
density f theta i, which is just
the conditional
density given Xi,
then I could still write this.
And now when I look at the
expectation of this guy, what
I'm going to be left with
is just 1 over n sum from i
equal 1 to n of the expectation
of log f theta i of Yi.
And it's basically the same
thing, except that I have a 1
over n expectation in front.
And I didn't tell you this,
because I only showed you
what the KL divergence was
for between two distributions.
But here, I'm telling
you what the KL
is between two products
of distributions
that are independent,
but not necessarily
identically distributed.
But that's what's going to
show up, just because it's
a product of things.
So when you have the log,
it's just going to be a sum.
Other questions?
All right, so what
do we do here?
Well, as I said, now we know
that the expectation of H
is negative Fisher information.
So rather than putting
H inverse in my iterates
for Newton-Raphson, I'm just
going to put the inverse Fisher
information.
And remember, it had
a minus sign in front.
So I'm just going to
pick up a plus sign now,
just because i is negative,
the expectation of the Hessian.
And this guy has, essentially,
the same convergence
properties.
And it just happens
that it's easier
to compute the i than H Ln.
And that's it.
That's really why
you want to do this.
Now, you might say that, well,
if I use more information,
I should do better, right?
But it's actually
not necessarily
true for several reasons.
But let's say that one is
probably the fact that I
did not use more information.
Every step when I was
computing this thing at xk,
I actually pretended
that at theta k
the true distribution
was the one distributed
according to theta k.
And that was not true.
This is only true
when theta k becomes
close to the true theta.
And so in a way, what
I gained I lost again
by making this thing.
It's just really a matter
of simple computation.
So let's just see it on
a particular example.
Actually, in this example, it's
not going to look much simpler.
It's actually going
to be the same.
All right, so I'm going to
have the Bernoulli example.
All right, so we
know that Bernoulli
belongs to the canonical
exponential family.
And essentially, all I
need to tell you what b is.
And b of theta for Bernoulli
is log 1 plus e theta, right?
We computed that.
OK.
And so when I look
at my log-likelihood,
it is going to look like the sum
from i equal 1 to n of Yi of--
OK, so here I'm
going to actually use
the canonical link.
So it's going to be
Xi transpose beta
minus log 1 plus exponential
Xi transpose beta.
And phi for this
guy is equal to 1.
Is it clear for
everyone what I did?
OK.
So remember the density,
so that was really just--
so the PMF was exponential Y
theta minus log 1 plus e theta.
There was actually
no normalization.
That's just the
density of a Bernoulli.
And the theta is actually
log p over 1 minus p.
And so that's what
actually gives me what my--
since p is the expectation,
this is actually
giving me also my
canonical link,
which is the log [? at link. ?]
We saw that last time.
And so if I start taking the log
of this guy and summing over n
and replacing theta by
Xi transpose beta, which
is what the canonical link
tells me to do, I get this guy.
Is that clear for everyone?
If it's not, please redo
this step on your own.
OK.
So I want to maximize
this function.
Sorry.
So I want to maximize
this function over there
on the first line as
a function of beta.
And so to do this, I want
to use either Newton-Raphson
or what I call Fisher-scoring.
So Fisher-scoring
is the second one,
when you replace the Hessian
by negative Fisher information.
So I replace these two things.
And so I first
take the gradient.
OK.
So let's take the
gradient of ln.
So the gradient of ln is
going to be, well, sum--
so here, this is of
the form Yi, which
is a scalar, times
a vector, Xi beta.
That's what I erased from here.
The gradient of b
transpose x is just b.
So here, I have just Yi Xi.
So that's of the form Yi,
which is a scalar, times Xi,
which is a vector.
Now, what about this guy?
Well, here I have a function.
So I'm going to have just the
usual rule, the chain rule,
right?
So that's just going
to be 1 over this guy.
And then I need to find
the Hessian of this thing.
So the 1 is going away.
And then I apply the
chain rule again.
So I get e of Xi
transpose beta, and then
the Hessian of this
thing, which is Xi.
So my Hessian--
my radiant, sorry,
I can actually factor
out all my Xi's.
And it's going to
look like this.
My gradient is a weighted
average or weighted sum
of the Xi's.
This will always
happen when you have
a generalized linear model.
And that's pretty clear.
Where did the Xi show up?
Whether it's from
this guy or that guy,
the Xi came from
the fact that when
I take the gradient
of Xi transpose beta,
I have this vector
Xi that comes out.
It's always going to be
the thing that comes out.
So I will always have something
that looks like with some sum
with some weights
here of the Xi's.
Now, when I look at
the second derivative--
so same thing, I'm just going
to take the derivative this guy.
Since nothing depends
on beta here or here,
I'm just going to have to take
the derivative of this thing.
And so it's going to be equal.
So if I look now at the Hessian
ln as a function of beta,
I'm going to have sum from i
equal 1 to n of, well, Yi--
what is a derivative of
Yi with respect to beta?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: What?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
0.
OK?
It doesn't depend on data.
I mean, this distribution does.
But Y itself is just
a number, right?
So this is 0.
So I'm going to get the minus.
And then I'm going to
have, again, the chain
rule that shows up.
So I need to find the
derivative of x over 1 plus x.
What is the derivative
of x over 1 plus x.
Actually don't even know.
So that gives me--
OK.
So that's 1 over
1 plus x squared.
So that's minus e
Xi transpose beta--
sorry, 1 divided by 1 plus e
Xi transpose beta squared times
the derivative of the
exponential, which is e Xi
transpose beta and again, Xi.
And then I have this
Xi that shows up.
But since I'm
looking for a matrix,
I'm going to have Xi,
Xi transpose, right?
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So I know
I'm going to need something that
looks like a matrix in the end.
And so one way you want
to think about it is this
is going to spit out an Xi.
There's already an Xi here.
So I'm going to have
something that looks like Xi.
And I'm going to have to
multiply by it another vector
Xi.
And I want it to form a matrix.
And so what you need to do
is to take an outer product.
And that's it.
So now as a result, the
updating rule is this.
Honestly, this is not
a result of anything.
I actually rewrote everything
that I had before with a theta
replaced by beta,
because it's just
painful to rewrite this entire
thing, put some big parenthesis
and put minus 1 here.
And then I would have to
put the gradient, which
is this thing here.
So as you can imagine,
this is not super nice.
Actually, what's
interesting is at some point
I mentioned there's a
pseudo-Newton method.
They're actually
doing exactly this.
They're saying, oh,
at each iteration,
I'm actually going to
just take those guys.
If I'm at iteration
k, I'm actually
just going to sum
those guys up to k
rather than going all the way
to n and look at every one.
So you're just looking at your
observations one at a time
based on where you were before.
OK.
So you have a matrix.
You need to invert it.
So if you want to be
able to invert it,
you need to make
sure that the sum
with those weights of Xi
outer, Xi, or Xi, Xi transpose
is invertible.
So that's a condition
that you need to have.
And well, you don't have
to, because technically you
don't need to invert.
You just need to solve
the linear system.
But that's actually guaranteed
in most of the cases
if n is large enough.
All right, so everybody
sees what we're doing here?
OK.
So that's for the
Newton-Raphson.
If I wanted to actually
do the Fisher-scoring,
all I would need to do is
to replace the Hessian here
by its expectation when I
pretend that the beta have,
iteration k, is the true one.
What is the expectation
of this thing?
And when I say
expectation here, I'm
always talking about conditional
expectation of Y given X.
The only distributions that
matter, that have mattered
in this entire chapter, are
conditional expectation of Y
given X.
The conditional expectation
of this thing given X is what?
It's itself.
It does not depend on Y.
It only depends on the X's.
So conditionally
on x, this thing
as far as we're concerned,
is completely deterministic.
So it's actually equal
to it's expectation.
And so in this
particular example,
there's no difference
between Fisher-scoring
and Newton-Raphson.
And the reason is because
the gradient no longer
depends on Yi--
I'm sorry.
The Hessian no
longer depends on Yi.
OK?
This slide is just repeating
some stuff that I've said.
OK.
So I think this is probably--
OK, let's go through
this actually.
At some point, I said
that Newton-Raphson--
do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
When would the gradient-- sorry,
the Hessian ever depend on Yi?
Because it seems like
Yi is just-- or at least
when you have a canonical link,
that the log-likelihood is just
[INAUDIBLE] to Yi Xi [INAUDIBLE]
theta and that's the only place
Y shows up.
So [INAUDIBLE] derivative
[INAUDIBLE] never depend on Y?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Not when
you have a canonical link.
AUDIENCE: So if it's not a
[INAUDIBLE] there's is no
difference between--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
So yeah, maybe I wanted you to
figure that out for yourself.
OK.
So Yi times Xi transpose beta.
So essentially, when I
have a general family, what
he's referring to is that this
is just b of Xi transpose beta.
So I'm going to take
some derivatives.
And there's going
to be something
complicated coming out of this.
But I'm certainly not going
to have some Yi showing up.
The only place where
Yi shows up is here.
Now, if I take two
derivatives, this thing
is gone, because it's linear.
The first one is going
to keep on like this guy.
And the second one is
going to make it go on.
The only way this actually shows
up is when to have an H here.
And if I have an H, then I
can take second derivatives.
And this thing is
not going to be
completely independent of beta.
Sorry.
Yeah, this thing is
still going to depend
on beta, which means
that this Yi term is not
going to disappear.
I believe we'll see an example
of that, or maybe I removed it.
I'm not sure, actually.
I think we will see an example.
So let us do a Iteratively
Re-weighted Least
Squares, or IRLS, which I've
actually recently learned
is a term that even though
it was defined in the '50s,
people still feel
free to use to define
to call their new algorithms
which have nothing
to do with this.
This is really something where
you actually do iteratively
re-weighted least squares.
OK.
Let's just actually go
through this quickly
what is going to be iteratively
re-weighted least squares.
The way the steps that
we had here showed up--
let's say those guys, x*--
is this, is when were actually
solving this linear system,
right?
That was the linear system
we were trying to solve.
But solving a
linear system can be
done by just trying
to minimize, right?
If I have x a and
b, it's the same
as minimizing the norm of
ax minus b squared over x.
If I can actually find
an x for which it's 0,
it means that I've
actually solved my problem.
And so that means that I can
solve linear systems by solving
least square problems.
And least square problems
are things that statisticians
are comfortable solving.
And so all I have to
do is to rephrase this
as at least square problem.
OK?
And you know, I could just
write it directly like this.
But there's a way to
streamline it a little bit.
And that's actually
by using weights.
OK.
So I've come in the weights--
well, not today, actually,
but very soon, all right?
So this is just a
reminder of what we had.
We have that's Yi give Xi as
a distribution distributed
according to some distribution
in the canonical exponential
family.
So that means that the
log-likelihood looks like this.
Again, this does
not matter to us.
This is the form that matters.
And we have a bunch
of relationships
that we actually spent
some time computing.
The first one is that mu
is b prime of theta i.
The second one is that
if I take g of mu i,
I get this systematic component,
Xi transpose beta that's
modeling.
Now, if I look at the derivative
mu i with respect to theta i,
this is the derivative
of b prime of theta i
with respect to theta i.
So that's the second derivative.
And I'm going to call it Vi.
If phi is equal to 1, this
is actually the variance.
And then I have this
function H, which
allows me to bypass altogether
the existence of this parameter
mu, which says if I want to
go from Xi transpose beta
all the way to theta i, I
have to first do g inverse,
and then b prime inverse.
If I stopped here, I
would just have mu.
OK?
OK.
So now what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to apply the chain rule.
And I'm going to try to
compute the derivative
of my log-likelihood
with respect to beta.
So, again, the
log-likelihood is much nicer
when I read it as a function of
theta than a function of beta,
but it's basically what
we've been doing by hand.
You can write it as a
derivative with respect
to theta first, and then
multiply by the derivative
of theta with respect to beta.
OK.
And we know that
theta depends on beta
as H of Xi transpose beta.
OK?
I mean, that's basically
what we've been
doing for the Bernoulli case.
I mean, we used the chain rule
without actually saying it.
But this is going to be
convenient to actually make
it explicitly show up.
OK.
So when I first take the
derivative of my log-likelihood
with respect to theta,
I'm going to use the fact
that my canonical
family is super simple.
OK.
So what I have is that
my log-likelihood ln
is the sum from i equal 1
to n of Yi theta i minus b
of theta i divided by phi
plus some constant, which
will go away as
soon as I'm going
to take my first derivative.
So if I take the derivative with
respect to theta i of this guy,
this is actually going to be
equal to Yi minus b prime theta
i divided by phi.
And then I need to multiply
by the derivative of theta i
with respect to beta.
Remember, theta is H
of Xi transpose beta.
So the derivative of theta
i with respect to beta j,
this is equal to H prime
of Xi transpose beta.
And then I have the
derivative of this guy.
Actually, let me just do
the gradient of theta I
at beta, right?
That's what we did.
I'm just thinking of theta i
as being a function of theta.
So what should I add here?
It was just the vector Xi, which
is just the chain rule again.
That's Hi prime, right?
You don't see it, but there's
a prime here that's derivative.
OK.
We've done that without
saying it explicitly.
So now if I multiply
those two things
I have this Yi minus
b prime of the theta
i, which I call by its
good name, which is mu i.
b prime of theta i
is the expectation
of Yi conditionally on Xi.
And then I multiply
by this thing here.
So here, this thing is written
coordinate by coordinate.
But I can write
it as a big vector
when I stack them together.
And so what I claim is
that this thing here
is of the form Y minus mu.
But here I put some tildes.
Because what I did is that
first I multiplied everything
by g prime of mu for each mu.
OK.
So why not?
Actually, on this slide it will
make no sense why I do this.
I basically multiply
by g prime on one side
and divide by g prime
on the other side.
So what I write so far is that
the gradient of ln with respect
to beta is the sum from i
equal 1 to n of Yi minus mu i,
let's call it,
divide by phi times
H prime of Xi transpose beta Xi.
OK.
So I just stacked
everything that's here.
And now I'm going to
start calling things.
The first thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to divide.
So this guy here I'm
going to push here.
Now, this guy here
I'm actually going
to multiply by g prime of mu i.
And this guy I'm going to
divide by g prime of mu i.
So there's really nothing
that happened here.
I just took g prime and multiply
and divide it by g prime.
Why do I do this?
Well, that's actually
going to be clear
when we talk about iteratively
re-weighted least squares.
But now, essentially I have
a new mu, a Y which is--
so this thing now is going
to be Y tilde minus mu
tilde, so i, i.
Now, this guy here
I'm going to call Wi.
And I have the Xi
that's there, which
means that now the thing that
I have here I can write as
follows.
Gradient ln of beta
is equal to what?
Well, I'm going to write
it in matrix forms.
So I have the sum over i of
something multiplied by Xi.
So I'm going to write
it as x transpose.
Then I'm going to have
this matrix W1 Wn, and then
0 elsewhere.
And then I'm going to
have my Y tilde minus mu.
And remember, X is the
matrix with-- sorry,
it should be a bit [INAUDIBLE].
I have n, and then p.
And here I have my Xi j in this
matrix on row i and column j.
And this is just a matrix that
has the Wi's on the diagonal.
And then I have
Y tilde minus mu.
So this is just the matrix
we're writing of this formula.
All right.
So it's just saying
that if I look
at the sum of weighted
things of my columns of Xi,
it's basically the same thing.
When I'm going to multiply
this by my matrix,
I'm going to get exactly
those terms, right?
Yi minus mu i tilde times Wi.
And then when I actually
take this Xi transpose
times this guy, I'm
really just getting
the sum of the columns
with the weights, right?
Agree?
If I look at this
thing here, this
is a vector that has S
coordinates, Wi times Yi
tilde minus mu i tilde.
And I have n of them.
So when I multiply X
transpose by this guy,
I'm just looking at a weighted
sum of the columns of X
transpose, which is a
weighted sum of the rows of X,
which are exactly my Xi's.
All right, and that's this
weighted sum of the Xi's.
OK.
So here, as I said,
the fact that we
decided to put this g prime of
mu i here and g prime of mu i
here, we could have
not done this, right?
We could have just said,
I forget about the tilde
and just call it Yi minus mu i.
And here, I just put everything
I don't know into some Wi.
And so why do I do this?
Well, it's because
when I actually
start looking at the Hessian,
what's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
We'll do that next time.
But let's just look quickly at
the outcome of the computation
of my Hessian.
So I compute a bunch
of second derivatives.
And here, I have
two terms, right?
Well, he's gone.
So I have two terms.
And when I take the
expectation now,
it's going to actually
change, right?
This thing is actually
going to depend on Yi.
Because I have an H which
is not the identity.
Oh, no, you're here, sorry.
So when I start looking
at the expectation,
so I look at the conditional
expectation given Xi.
The first term here has
a Yi minus expectation.
So when I take the
conditional expectation,
this is going to be 0.
The first term is
going away when I take
the conditional expectation.
But this was
actually gone already
if we had the canonical term,
because the second derivative
of H when H is
the identity is 0.
But if H is not the identity,
H prime prime may not be 0.
And so I need that part
to remove that term.
And so now, you know,
I work a little bit,
and I get this term.
That's not very surprising.
In the second derivative, I see
I have terms in b prime prime.
I have term in H
prime, but squared.
And then I have my Xi
outer Xi, Xi, Xi transpose,
which we know we would see.
OK.
So we'll go through
those things next time.
But what I want to show you is
that now once I compute this,
I can actually show that if
I look at this product that
showed up, I had b prime
prime times H prime squared.
One of those terms is
actually 1 over g prime.
And so I can rewrite it
as one of the H primes,
because I had a square,
divided by g prime.
And now, I have this
Xi Xi transpose.
So if I did not put
the g prime in the W
that I put here
completely artificially,
I would not be able to call
this guy Wi, which is exactly
what it is from this board.
And now that this guy is Wi, I
can actually write this thing
here as X transpose WX.
OK?
And that's why I
really wanted my W
to have this g prime of
mu i in the denominator.
Because now I can actually
write a term that depends on W.
Now, you might say, how do I
reconcile those two things?
What the hell are you doing?
And what the hell I'm
doing is essentially
that I'm saying that if
you write beta k according
to the Fisher-scoring
iterations,
you can actually write it
as just this term here,
which is of the form X transpose
X inverse X transpose Y.
But I actually
squeezed in these W's.
And that's actually a
weighted least square.
And it's applied to
this particular guy.
So we'll talk about those
weighted least squares.
But remember, least
squares is of the form--
beta hat is X transpose
X inverse X transpose Y.
And here it's basically
the same thing,
except that I squeeze in
some W after my X transpose.
OK.
So that's how we're
going to solve it.
I don't want to go
into the details
now, mostly because we're
running out of time.
Are there any questions?